so basically the Taliban banned women
from being in universities and colleges
at the moment what they have had
basically before coming up for a while
is that we are trying to make the
institutions more shittier compliant not
that we're trying to take away their
education and because of that they
basically stopped all women from
attending University and college until
further notice not a permanent ban they
basically just said just until for the
notice they're trying to make emotional
compliant now the West is obviously
going to use this as just propaganda and
they're basically nailing it in and you
see people like Piers Morgan asking
Andrew Tate about it and talking about
how what are your thoughts on that is it
fair is it just you see Western media
using big labels like Taliban bands
women's basic rights and they love this
they love this type of stuff they'll eat
it up one thing one thing I've learned
to never trust is these big media
Outlets titles ever ever and I'll give
one example one example because this is
something it came across recently and I
think it'll really help you know so
notified the message the guardian
reported
6 500 people 6 500 migrant workers
were offed due to
Kotor announcing the World Cup
or since Qatar announced they're going
to be hosting the World Cup they said
something like that you can go look it
up right now what that seems like is
Qatar having migrant workers build the
stadium cause the death of I mean the
offing of 6 500 migrant workers
what does that number actually show
what does that number actually show that
and they say in the article the number
6500 is the number of Migrant workers
who
left
this Earth no matter how they left no
matter what they were doing
within the country in the last 12 years
since it was decided that's where the
World Cups can be hosted and you see
people tick tock saying oh 6 500 people
whatever that was a lie that's literally
a misleading title so I'm not gonna ever
believe what people are saying but on
this note
it's very important now again we look at
the root if if they are ruling or even
in their own estimation based on the
Sharia right and I don't know much about
them but if they are they don't go based
off of a liberalism and democracy so to
expect them to act like the West is is
fallacious it's purely ethnocentrism
it's it's it's just an ideal uh an
ideological difference
you might think that's wrong whatever
prove it that's what I'm asking you to
prove that your ideologies right their
ideology is wrong at the root level
otherwise you can complain about XYZ
them if their intention is to only have
the brothers go to school until they
could build sister only schools and then
segregate I think that's beautiful go
for it doesn't make it easy for them if
their goal is to completely ruin and not
have a woman learn Islam at all
or learn educate uh educate themselves
on anything that's completely unislamic
that's completely wrong and that's not
something as far as I know Islam would
allow foreign
opinions but as far as I know that's not
something that Islam actually allows I
had this conversation earlier and even
me and on who were talking about it that
why didn't they ban men from school why
didn't they ban men from going there
well as as Muslims falling and
practicing Islam we believe that men are
responsible to be providers and
protectors over women so why would it
not make sense that they continue to
basically strive to be the next
Generations of Breadwinners the most
until in the meantime that we can get
our act together with the Sharia
compliance and with the rules and
regulations and code of conduct that we
have
firmly rooted in Islam to the best of
our abilities does that not make sense
bro yeah yeah and I mean sorry on hell
you should go inshallah
unless you're gonna say we shouldn't
talk about it then I'm gonna go ahead
and I was gonna say I mean if you think
about our fitra our natural disposition
or just let's look at how people live
the last you know thousands of years it
was always the men going out being the
go-getters being the the Breadwinners
whatever even if it meant they have to
learn something a skill first and then
go work based off that skill it was
always the men doing this this is how
the world has worked this is how men and
women live for thousands of years and
it's something that worked and this is
always something that people naturally
fell into these gender roles and
whatever you want to call it so why
would it be any different in this case
let the men work let the men learn let
the men you know go to school mothers
have very women have very important
roles that men just can't do like be a
mother men cannot be moms men cannot
give birth men cannot breastfeed men are
not as empathetic as women just
literally just based on blood flowing to
certain parts of the brain that make
women more empathetic it's a natural
thing and Allah has created very
beautifully a woman for for with very
beautiful qualities that a man just does
not have us naturally and same thing
with a man Allah has created men with
very beautiful characteristics that
women don't have
like for example the 30 extra muscle
mass we have you know women have wider
hips so they can give birth it makes it
harder for them to move and do physical
labor for men it's easier
so listen you can justify or not just
fire all you want you can go into these
semantics all you want at the end of the
day if you want to make an argument make
it sound go to the root prove whatever
you need to prove but you guys are not
going to be able to prove that oh
liberalism is just the ideology this is
the same style media propaganda that you
saw with Qatar as soon as they said that
we don't want this rainbow nonsense in
our sports teams this is soccer bro
forget even these are our values you're
disrespecting let's keep it at soccer
ball let's keep it at football none of
this rainbow stuff the media ate that up
bro but the problem that they're saying
which is what Ram is alluding to is that
the West
operates in this almost false sense of
we have what's correct we almost
presuppose to be objective truth who
says who
says who because you guys didn't even
believe what you believe in like 10
years ago 15 years ago 20 years ago
and Islam is the only solution that is
objectively grounded in Morality
you were going to say something earlier
oh what are we doing what are we talking
about right now
I feel like this is like the radio talk
show right now
well I mean for people on audio that's
maybe exactly what they need
yeah that's true I never thought about
that What's um
so did they cut off all education or is
it just like the higher forms of
Education like college I think it's
college and university just until
further notice
okay well I mean the women are still
getting uh basic level
even more than that of knowledge I mean
University if you think about a
university just setting you up for the
system
it's setting you up to learn a career
path
you know like I don't know
maybe they are doing something different
maybe they're not
if if anyone really take any message
from this I think the most important
thing is that you should never just take
Word of Mouth even if it's like a news
article news organization you should
never just take people's Word of Mouth
you should never just take whatever
people say
um especially when it's going on abroad
and just accept it with open arms
because a lot of the time it's
propaganda a lot of the time it's not
true or it's Amplified or just context
is taken away like imagine I told you I
think I've used this example a few times
but imagine I told you
um uh so-and-so pushed an old lady
industry actually let me use a better
example uh this actually happened what
I'm telling you now actually happened
a woman
at Walmart an old lady an old lady at
Walmart would not move
from in the middle of the doorway she
was literally just in the middle of the
doorway she wouldn't move so I pushed
her
I swear to God will Allah happened
I did that I pushed an old lady she was
in the middle of the doorway you're
probably thinking you're probably
thinking the Romney's a disgusting guy
cancel I mean she was in one of those
motorized vehicles
and there was a crack in the concrete
before the door so the back wheel got
stuck and she couldn't move so I pushed
the the thing forward so I could gain
traction and she could go
the first version everyone hates me the
second version is like oh okay that's a
nice thing to do just because I gave
more context because a lot of things in
isolation sound really bad
so don't just take word of mouth without
saying the full story as Muslims we're
not supposed to do that either by the
way Allah says in the Quran
um whenever you're given information
from like a non-not so trust with your
Source here and skeptical about them you
need to verify it Allah Quran